you guys are doing well Congrats on the
movie so you here say I wanted to start
with you on this one because it's your
first animated feature and I was
wondering it did your episode of Bojack
prep you enough for this or is there
anything about the voice acting process
that took some serious getting used to
yeah I've done a few episodes and
animation things like that this is my
first feature so I think that the
process of it was new which the one
episode of Project Horseman could not
prepare me for but I'm doing a series
now that I can say a scooby-doo prepped
me for this so valuable you learned
while doing your voice work on Scooby a
valuable lesson I learned well do my
voice to work on Scooby it would
probably be getting comfortable with the
efforts and just like getting over the
fact that you're gonna have to make
grunting noises that are gonna sound
weird and we don't like that and you
hope that they're never taken out of
context you cannot no and ever use them
it's very very understandable can you on
the other hand are kind of like up to
your eyeballs in animated experience so
for you is there anything that needs to
stay consistent on all of your animated
features or is it a different experience
from film to film it's definitely a
different experience from film to film
and you I think the challenge now is to
make every experience unique and I think
that it's always the first day of doing
an animated movie when you're really
discovering that character and you're
kind of collaborating with the writers
and producers and directors and we're
kind of figuring out what the voices and
what made this special for me personally
it was you know we all decided that we
should use something as close to my
normal voice you know and because um you
know more of like a I guess a sarcastic
voice of reason which I'm not really
I don't play roles like that typically
and it was really nice to reference
maybe the more parental side of me you
know having two daughters and I so while
I would while I would be what would be
taping this I would be thinking more of
as a parent kind of referencing that
kind of dynamic and
to kind of ground the character a little
bit and then adding a little bit of
sarcasm here and there but I just like
how understated it is but then when you
watch an anime and you know you know he
saves the day in a few spots so there's
a lot of new fresh dynamics for me that
I never experienced before an animation
and to me that really does keep it fun
you know it really does I'm not sure
which order you shot these in but was
there anything that you did on Scoob
that helped you at Tom and Jerry or vice
versa as far as you know bringing a
hanna-barbera project to the big screen
in the best way possible
that's a great question hanna-barbera is
more kind of a hybrid live-action so I
was more of a live-action character in
Tom and Jerry so so it's a bit so it to
me I consider them two unique distinct
entities so to me you know that was more
of a real life you know live-action you
know performance but but definitely with
Dinah mods it's really one of my
favorite characters and the more I think
about it as we're doing this today it's
like wow this really cool will be part
of the history of that yeah it's really
really cool in honor of Shaggy and
Scooby's meal choices what is the most
ridiculous or outrageous thing you make
yourselves to eat the most ridiculous
thing you made myself to eat I don't
know I make ridiculous salads and I'll
put literally anything on it like just
pickles sandwich meat all day Keirsey I
was just about to say that myself
because sometimes my wife the other day
was making like salmon like teriyaki
salmon rice and salad and and it's not
all the time I'll be just like you know
just put that in a bowl please you know
and like everybody else will have like
in the plate in the bowl and I'll just
like you know what you know I don't want
to watch that many dishes put in one
Bowl in a bowl
in a bowl mix it all up on the same
uh-huh and then throw pickles on it
pickles anything yeah I'm gonna go order
a salad right now and put pickles on it
so I'm trusting you yeah do it it gives
like a nice flavor you know just that
vinegary moment you need a little acid
in it so yeah all right I'm trusting you
on it thanks for the recommendation and
congratulations on the movie thank you
so much